[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin ihnen allen guten abend für
den sport ist kristin otto wieder hier
bei uns sehr gerne guten abend und das
sind die themen des tages
rauchsäulen über lemberg die
luftangriffe auf die ukraine gehen
weiter aber am boden scheinen die
russischen truppen kaum voran zu kommen
großkundgebung in moskau präsident putin
lobt die streitkräfte aber im
staatsfernsehen wird seine rede
unterbrach die
lockerungen trotz steigender zahlen
bundestag und bundesrat beschließen das
umstrittene
infektionsschutzgesetz und in den
krankenhäusern liegen immer mehr corona
patienten
die diplomatischen drähte laufen weiter
heißt der kanzler telefonierte heute mit
putin chinas präsident hu mit dem
us-präsidenten und bei ihm also joe
biden bedankte sich ukraine präsident
selent ski für zitat neue und effektive
hilfe offenbar gemünzt auf
waffenlieferungen nach
experteneinschätzungen wohl mit ein
grund warum russlands bodenoffensive
stockt aus der luft greifen die kreml
truppen aber weiter landesweit ziele an
christoph destor l und lena sünder bruch
es sind immer dieselben schwer zu
ertragenden bilder diesmal wieder aus
kiew von menschen deren häuser in schutt
gepumpt sind von verletzten und toten
über 60 zivilisten sollen inzwischen
allein in der hauptstadt ums leben
gekommen sein doch trotz der zerstörung
zeichnet sich eins zunehmend ab die
ukraine hält weiter der russischen
übermacht stand die worte ihres
präsidenten wohl mehr als
durchhalteparolen
die besatzer dachten sie treffen auf die
harmlose ukraine die sie von 2014 und
2015 kannten die sie bestechen konnten
aber wir sind jetzt jemand anderes und
das hilft uns die angriffe weiträumig
abzuwehren
täglich veröffentlicht russland seine
bilder und erfolgsmeldungen heute zu den
separatisten gebieten im osten
mit hilfe der russischen armee haben die
kräfte der volksrepublik lohans gut 90
prozent der region unter ihre kontrolle
gebracht
dagegen stecken im süden und rund um
kiew die bodentruppen offenbar fest
militärexperten sagen irgendwann sinke
im feld die kampfkraft rapide ab es
könnte so weit sein wir sehen die bilder
wie soldaten russische soldaten in
panzern in fahrzeugen schlafen müssen
oder in improvisierten zelten im matsch
liegen über wochen das schwächt
natürlich die kampfmoral zusätzlich zu
anderen faktoren russland werbe jetzt
ausländische söldner an heißt es aber
materialverlust und kriegskosten würden
aus russischer sicht zu einem problem
meinen experten gleichzeitig bekomme die
ukraine vom westen laufend neue waffen
was zum beispiel dazu führt dass die
russen noch immer nicht die
luftüberlegenheit haben über dem
ukrainischen staatsgebiet was eigentlich
für eine militärische operation immer
ein riesiger vorteil ist vorerst aber
bluten vor allem die umkämpften städte
weiter aus etwa das eingekesselte mario
pohl apokalyptische straßenszenen von
weit über 2.000 toten bislang spricht
der stadtrat
immerhin aus dem bombardierten theater
dort konnten wohl alle eingeschlossenen
menschen gerettet werden nur einen
verletzten soll es geben aber auch das
passierte heute wieder flogen
marschflugkörper vom schwarzen meer aus
bis fast heran an die eu grenze zu polen
zielflughafen lemberg direkt am
stadtrand
vier der abgeschossenen raketen kamen
durch und trafen das werk für
flugzeugwartung zwei weitere wurden
abgefangen
heißt wenn stimmt auch nach zwei wochen
krieg ist die ukrainische luftabwehr
mindestens teilweise noch einsatzfähig
vom westen in den süden des landes in
die hafenstadt odessa dort ist es noch
vergleichsweise ruhig aber man rechnet
dort jederzeit mit größeren und
schwereren angriffen und wie im rest des
landes verstehen sich sehr viele
bürgerinnen und bürger in diesen zeiten
auch als soldaten gemeinsam bereiten sie
sich auf den ernstfall vor beobachtet
katrin eigendorf
an den stränden von odessa wo im sommer
die touristen sondern füllen sie jetzt
zu hunderten sand in säcke ab zur
verteidigung ihrer stadt hier am
schwarzen meer fürchten sie könnte die
russische marine angreifen denn die
drittgrößte hafenstadt der ukraine ist
ein strategisch wichtiges ziel überall
haben sie barrikaden errichtet niemand
kommt hier mehr durch überall haben
soldaten positionen bezogen auf einem
abgelegenen fabrikgelände erklärt jean
ja wie man eine kalaschnikow bedient wie
waffentraining im schnellverfahren
sind lehrerinnen unternehmer mütter ganz
normale bürger oder saß keiner von ihnen
hier glaubt daran dass sich dieser krieg
auf verhandlungsweg lösen lässt deswegen
wollen sie alle hier lernen sich selbst
zu verteidigen drei wochen krieg das hat
alles verändert die schrecklichen bilder
die angst dass russische panzer auch auf
ihre stadt zurollen ist sie wirklich
bereit zu kämpfen frage ich eine der
frauen
mit jedem tag scheint mir bin ich dazu
mehr bereit denn jeden tag töten sie
unsere kinder das ist sehr schmerzhaft
roger wir lernen mit der waffe umzugehen
denn im falle der kriegs aktivitäten
laufen wir nicht zurück wir werden hier
stehen bis zum 1 dazu sind sie alle hier
entschlossen egal wie gut sie am ende
wirklich schießen können ihr land zu
verlassen aufzugeben das ist für keinen
von ihnen hier eine option
während russische soldaten kämpfen und
sterben wird in der heimat gefeiert und
zwar der achte jahrestag der krim
annexion präsident putin nutzte das um
vor zehntausenden in einer moskauer
arena den angriffskrieg zu rechtfertigen
übertragen vom staatsfernsehen plötzlich
sorgt ein moment international für
irritationen
wie christian sun berichtet als wladimir
putin gerade über die in russland so
genannte militäroperationen in der
ukraine spricht die rede im
staatsfernsehen
plötzlich ab
stattdessen alec dass man oft mit
patriotischem pop ungewöhnlich so ein
fehler in der minuziös geplanten
präsidenten- show der raum für
spekulationen lässt sabotage oder den
falschen knopf gedrückt ein technischer
fehler sei das gewesen heißt es später
aus dem kreml eigentlich meidet wladimir
putin seit corona beginnen öffentliche
auftritte so gut es geht doch ein
vollbesetztes luschniki stadion am
jahrestag der krim annexion lässt sich
putin als kulisse nicht entgehen und er
verspricht einen militärischen erfolg in
der ukraine
die menschen gerade von diesen leiden zu
befreien von diesen genozid das ist der
hauptgrund der wichtigste grund das
auslösende motiv und ziel der
militäroperationen wie wir im donbass
und in der ukraine begonnen haben
putin wird nicht müde die geschichte
über den angeblichen gehen und sieht im
donbass wieder und wieder zu wiederholen
aber es stimmt nicht belege dafür gibt
es weiter keine rentner studenten
staatsbedienstete waren aufgefordert
worden hierher zu kommen um zu jubeln
also lieber nichts falsches sagen
wissen sie worum es heute geht ja es
geht um den grim beitritt was bedeutet
das für sie ich will nicht über sprechen
ich mag seine politik meine ganze
familie unterstützt ihn meine freunde
unterstützen ihn wladimir
wladimirowitsch ist unser präsident
putin lobt noch die russischen soldaten
für ihren einsatz und er sagt schon
lange gab es bei uns keine solche
einheit
organisierter jubel im luschniki seine
gegner hat putin längst ausgeschaltet
der krieg in der ukraine darum ging es
auch bei einem knapp zweistündigen
videogespräch dass us-präsident beiden
und chinas staatschef hu jintao
miteinander führten die usa befürchten
dass china russland militärische hilfe
leisten könnte und drohen für diesen
fall mit konsequenzen
bislang hat china sich nicht von
russland distanziert holen wir jetzt
unseren korrespondenten ulf röller in
peking dazu auf was ist herausgekommen
bei diesem gespräch und wie darf man
chinas position verstehen
also es hat ja im vorfeld des gesprächs
doch eine ziemlich aggressive rhetorik
gegeben zwischen peking und washington
zuschnitt usa und china beide seiten
haben sich mit massiven sanktionen
bedroht wegen des ukraine konfliktes
wenn man sich jetzt die
abschlusserklärung der chinesen von dem
gespräch anguckt ist der ton doch
wesentlich versöhnlicher
sie spricht davon dass die usa und china
mehr oder weniger die verpflichtung
haben frieden zu schaffen allerdings wie
das genau gehen soll ist schwer zu sagen
denn die chinesische position bleibt
weiter widersprüchlich auf der eine
seite verurteilt peking den krieg auf
der anderen seite distanziert man sich
nicht von russland peking versucht sich
ein bisschen als eine neutrale position
darzustellen aber es wird sehr sehr
schwer sein dies durchzuhalten peking
versucht vor allem weiter die west mit
dem westen die wirtschaftsbeziehungen zu
pflegen weil die sehr sehr wichtig sind
für die wirtschaftliche lage in china
aber eben auch nicht die geostrategische
position mit russland aufzugehen am ende
glaube ich wird überhaupt nur peking die
seiten wechseln wenn wirklich moskau und
putin an massiven machtverlust erlebt
wenn seine macht wackelt weil am ende
gilt für china eben dass das wichtigste
für china china heißt danke für die
einschätzung ulf röller nach peking
jetzt nach deutschland fast 200.000
flüchtlinge aus der ukraine sind hier
mittlerweile registriert worden eine
immer größere herausforderung für die
kommunen die auf klarer
finanzierungszusagen vom bund drängen
der hauptgeschäftsführer gerade städte
und gemeindebundes landsberg sagte die
beschlüsse der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz von gestern
reicht nicht aus der bund hatte zwar
generell hilfen in aussicht gestellt
aber noch keine konkrete höhe genannt
die hilfsbereitschaft in deutschland ist
weiter hoch über das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe haben sie bereits fast
116 millionen euro gespendet und spenden
sind natürlich weiterhin nötig und
möglich hier nochmal alle infos die bahn
de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100 das
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine
nachzulesen alles auch unter spenden
zdf.de oder auf der zdf textseite 890
zum thema corona da müssen wir uns alle
auf neue regeln einstellen denn die
bisherigen maßnahmen laufen morgen aus
ab sonntag gilt das neue
infektionsschutzgesetzes wurde heute
verabschiedet trotz massiver kritik der
opposition und der bundesländer dazu
gleich mehr zunächst erklärt axel konrad
die wichtigsten änderungen
kein abstand keine masken keine
zugangsbeschränkungen mehr es wird fast
wie früher einzige ausnahme in bussen
bahnen und flugzeugen hier bleibt auch
ab sonntag die maske bundesweit pflicht
der rest wird sache der länder die
können die maske weiter anordnen aber
nur in sensiblen bereichen wie etwa in
krankenhäusern arztpraxen und
pflegeeinrichtungen auch eine
testpflicht kann es dort dann weiterhin
geben genauso wie in schulen und
kindergärten
und dann gibt es noch die sogenannten
hotspot regelung sie greift wenn lokal
die gesundheitsversorgung bedroht ist
diese kritische corona lage müssen die
landesparlamente feststellen doch die
länder monieren dafür fehlten
einheitliche kriterien aber masken
testen abstand all das ist im krisenfall
dann wieder möglich für das neue gesetz
gilt eine übergangsfrist bis zum 2 april
mehrere bundesländer wollen sie nutzen
weitere zwei wochen bleibt dort dann
alles beim alten
also gerade gehört zentrale corona
maßnahmen fallen im neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz weg viele
kritisieren dass weil die
infektionszahlen weiterhin höchststände
erreichen und so gab es bei der
verabschiedung des gesetzes
erwartungsgemäß einen heftigen
schlagabtausch ines trams berichtet aus
bundestag und bundesrat
von einem schweren komponist spricht
gesundheitsminister und epidemiologe
lauterbach doch er verweist auf eine
neue lage wohl auch aufgrund des drucks
vom koalitionspartner fdp wir können
nicht weiter das gesamte land unter
schutz stellen um eine kleine gruppe von
impfwilligen
und denjenigen die berater nicht bereit
sind die massnahmen mitzutragen um diese
zu schützen
zugunsten der viele in der partei
genannt fdp geben bundesregierung und
gesundheitsminister der ansonsten der
ewige mahner in der pandemie gewesen ist
hier eine politische bankrotterklärung
ab es gilt den koalitionsfrieden zu
wahren spd und grüne gehen widerwillig
mit zufrieden scheint nur die fdp sie
setzt auf das prinzip eigenverantwortung
die menschen in deutschland sind ja
keine kleinen kinder wir verbieten
niemanden masken zu tragen wir
ermöglichen den menschen ihre eigene
verantwortung selbst die hand das spur
kern auf einer liberal die union spricht
von wirrwarr in hotspots soll es den
ländern erlaubt seinen schärfere
maßnahmen zu verhängt doch wann ist eine
region ein hotspot sie sagen in
bereichen wo besonders wo neue
infektionen kommen kann reagiert werden
keiner weiß was meinen sie mit besonders
hohem neuinfektionen mit der mehrheit
der ampel stimmt der bundestag für das
gesetz auch der bundesrat winkt es durch
unter protest aller bundesländer
das verfahren ist unsäglich die länder
sind keiner weise beteiligt worden aber
er hat es auch inhaltlich für falsch
doch hätte der bundesrat das gesetz
blockiert würden ab morgen gar keine
regeln mehr gelten da das alte gesetz
ausläuft
jetzt schauen wir jetzt auf die korona
zahlen die steigen weiter deutlich an
erstmals liegt die sieben tage incidents
über 1700 genauer bei 1.700 6,3 das
macht sich auch in den krankenhäusern
bemerkbar immer mehr personal fällt aus
gleichzeitig kommen mehr kranke laut
aktuellen zahlen werden auf
intensivstationen
2247 patienten behandelt
8,5 prozent mehr als vor einer woche auf
den normal stationen liegen 21
1558 patienten mit corona das plus hier
noch größer 15,4 prozent sibylle bassler
berichtet aus einer klinik in nürnberg
steigen der inzidenz nur die hohe anzahl
an neuinfektionen auch durch die neue
omikron variante ba2 im klinikum
nürnberg beobachtet man diese
entwicklung mit großer sorge sind in
einer 6 wir haben zwei das ist
infektiöse überträgt sich viel schneller
wir haben auch weiterhin einzelne
schwere krankheitsverläufe wie in vielen
kliniken nimmt auch hier die zahl der
erkrankten zu im moment sind es 180
corona patienten 17 davon liegen auf
intensiv
und während patienten wie auch lange
zeit mit omikron bei unserer station
liegen und wir haben auch nikon
patienten die anderen sterben über 200
sind es bundesweit pro tag hauptsächlich
ungeimpfte aber auch geimpfte darunter
ältere oder immungeschwächte patienten
mit vorerkrankungen sind gefährdet
raff gori check hatte sich trotz
zweifacher impfung im februar angesteckt
der 73 jährige leidet noch immer unter
akuter atemnot was dieses virus
anrichten kann sehen sie hier jeden tag
um so näher nerve das aktuelle hits und
die korona bestimmungen dass man einen
frieden weight beschließt das ist völlig
egal dass
man auch keine generelle impfpflicht hat
dass man kein durchgängiges konzept
überhaupt hat und jetzt plötzlich
lockerungen macht das ist nicht zu
verstehen denn eines sei klar so der
chefarzt diese welle wird nicht die
letzte sein weitere virus mutationen
werden folgen
ausführliche zahlen und grafiken zu
krone wie immer in unserer zdf heute app
und zum neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz haben wir dort
auch eine einschätzung der biologin
ulrike protzer in gut einer woche welt
das saarland seinen neuen landtag diese
wahl dürfte spannend werden weil die cdu
von ministerpräsident hans damit rechnen
muss ihre position als stärkste kraft zu
verlieren im zdf politbarometer liegt
die spd klar vorne bislang ist sie der
juniorpartner in der regierenden
schwarz-roten koalition susanne freitag
berichtet wäre am sonntag landtagswahl
käme die cdu auf 30 prozent die spd
würde mit 39 prozent stärkste kraft die
linke wäre nicht mehr im landtag afd und
grüne liegen mit je sechs prozent
gleichauf die fdp käme wieder ins
parlament ministerpräsident tobias hans
kann nicht vom amtsbonus profitieren im
gegenteil eine mehrheit von 52 prozent
wünscht sich
spd-herausforderin anke rehlinger als
ministerpräsident in nur 31 prozent sind
für den amtsinhaber
in der frage bei welchen themen die
parteien für kompetent gehalten werden
liegt die spd in den bereichen
arbeitsplätze und wirtschaft deutlich
vor der cdu in der korona politik halten
30 prozent die cdu für kompetenter beim
thema bildung wiederum die spd die
kleineren parteien spielen bei dieser
wahl offenbar eine untergeordnete rolle
bei der frage nach möglichen
koalitionsmodelle befürworten 48 prozent
der befragten eine spd geführte gruppe
im angebot jetzt mein sport frust und
freude im fußball es geht um die europa
league für die deutsche mannschaft naja
gegen nicht überall ganz glatt für
leverkusen vor allem die bayer-elf
konnte den ausfall von florian würz
nicht kompensieren unterlag im rückspiel
zuhause atalanta bergamo mit 0 1 und
schied im achtelfinale aus nervenkitzel
bei frankfurt die eintracht sicherte
sich arbeit das weiterkommen mit einem
last minute treffer gegen betis sevilla
er ist das zittern dann der jubel für
eintracht frankfurt gibt es
international so scheint mal wieder kein
halten eins zu eins mit der letzten
aktion der verlängerung halb hinteregger
halb eigentor viertelfinale liebst du
nur ein fußballer in der neunzigsten
denkst du dir bericht kurz die fußball
welt zusammen und in der 120 steht die
fußballwelt wieder rosarot beetes mit
der führung in der neunzigsten minute in
der verlängerung die eintracht aber mit
den besseren nerven tor weiterkommen zur
belohnung gab es heute den fc barcelona
als nächsten gegner einer absoluten
topclubs im europäischen klubfußball ich
denke dass sich die ganze stadt der
ganze verein die fans die mannschaft
hier alle dieses los auch verdient haben
großer name schweres los oder die sich
in frankfurt sagen die nächste party
und frankfurts nächsten
bundesliga-gegner rb leipzig wurde
atalanta bergamo zugelost im
viertelfinale der champions league darf
bayern münchen spaniens fc villarreal
nicht unterschätzen in der
vorschlussrunde könnte es dann zum duell
mit jürgen klopps fc liverpool kommen
russlands nationalmannschaft bleibt
wegen des ukraine kriegs von den
playoffs zur fußball wm in katar
ausgeschlossen der internationale
sportgerichtshof cas lehnte den
einspruch der russen gegen die fifa
entscheiden zum teilnahmeverbot ab und
noch wintersport kein deutscher
podestplatz zum auftakt des biathlon
weltcup finales am holmenkollen in oslo
im sprint der männer kamen aber vier
deutsche unter die top 8 wobei benedikt
doll als vierter der beste war den
tagessieg sicherte sich der norweger
sturla holm
freude auch bei seiner teamgefährtin
thierry lag hofft sie war die schnellste
bei den frauen für einzel
olympiasiegerin denise herrmann reichte
es zu platz 7 franziska hildebrand wurde
neunter und jede menge wintersport
morgen live hier bei uns im zdf von 10
und 20 vielen dank
so morgen wird es für die meisten sonnig
im osten aber auch mal ein bisschen nass
mehr zum wetter gleich mit katja
horneffer ab 22 uhr neueste
informationen und einschätzungen von
marietta slomka im heute-journal so
viele von uns kommen sie gut ins
wochenende und haben einen entspannten
abend danke fürs interesse und bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten abend das hoch beschäftigt uns
nicht nur am wochenende sondern auch
kommende woche es zieht mal ein bisschen
nach osten dann in richtung südwesten
und die farben die sie hier sehen das
sind die temperaturen etwa anderthalb
kilometer über unseren köpfen
konzentrieren sie sich jetzt bitte mal
auf diese hellblaue farbe zwischen
berlin und warschau denn hier zieht ein
kleiner kaltluft tropfen richtung westen
dann über großbritannien und erreicht
bis mittwoch sogar norwegen dieser
kaltluft von macht sich morgen bei uns
bemerkbar noch nicht in dieser nacht da
gibt es einige wolkenfelder noch in
thüringen und sachsen häufig ist es klar
ist plötzlich auch mal nebel und zum
teil weht ein recht böiger wind aus
östlichen richtungen die temperaturen
dazu sinken auf plus fünf bis minus zwei
grad und steigen morgen über tag in den
östlichen mittelgebirgen auf 6 an der
ostsee auf 7 sonst meist auf 9 bis 12
grad und am rhein geht es auf 14 oder 15
grad rauf denn ganz im westen scheint
morgen die sonne strahlen sonst aber
macht sich dieser kaltluft tropfen
bemerkbar mit einzelnen kleinen schauern
oberhalb von 600 metern in den
mittelgebirgen kann auch mal ein
bisschen schnee regen dabei sein am
sonntag gibt es vielleicht ein paar
schauer richtung frankreich sonst
dominiert sonnenschein und in der neuen
woche wird es immer milder und sonniger
guten abend